il est des soirs où on est heureux on
est heureux parce qu'on a l'impression
qu'il se passe quelque chose et qu'on y
participe
je ne crois pas que vous pouvez imaginer
à quel point toute l'équipe de planète
bleue est fier de vous compter parmi ses
téléspectateurs en ce moment en direct
mesdames messieurs bonsoir et bienvenue
sur planète bleue planète bleue vous
parlera tout au long de l'année à 20h30
le premier mercredi du mois de la
planète vous prendrez également de ses
habitants les hommes de leurs craintes
et puis de leurs espoirs pour l'avenir
grâce à la science ce soir un premier
thème est bien la nourriture
l'alimentation nous allons parler si
l'on peut dire de notre estomac de notre
intestin
c'est pas toujours très gai mais
regardez tout de même l'actualité nous
accueille et nous nous rendrons pour
voir ces scientifiques et ses preuves
scientifiques d'abord en espagne vous
savez de l'huile frelatée a fait déjà
plus de 230 victimes tous poitiers nous
derrière les pyrénées ils nous rendront
dans des forêts beaucoup plus commune où
cette fois ci il y à des champignons
genre amanite phalloïde qui tue 12 cents
personnes sont ainsi touchées chaque
année en france
autres régions nous nous rendrons et
bien en méditerranée en écart année car
là on découvre qu'il y à la fois il ya
il ya du thon est ce ton et bien il a il
pose des problèmes ce ton il contient
peut-être du mercure
d'abord un autre endroit où nous irons à
pont-saint-esprit en france égard et
vous qu'en 1951 là bas du pain du pain à
empoisonner du simple le pain 230
personnes sont devenues folles 5 et bien
ma foi sont mortes et nous sommes allés
sur les traces de ce pain maudit de
pont-saint-esprit enfin nous partirons
un petit coup au sénégal pour boire un
verre de lait et on se rend compte que
cela est ma foi
lui aussi il y a deux ans a fait peur
mais vous me direz on est ce qu'on va
vous faire peur pendant cette émission
oui et non car je pense qu'on va
également tenter de vous rassurer pour
vous montrer que des scientifiques font
des efforts pourquoi nous nous rendrons
dans
en deux laboratoires français nous
rendrons à montpellier et nous nous
rendrons à clermont sur oise à clermont
sur oise en direct martin dupuis bonsoir
sur le rang et vérifie pas du mercure
pas d'athlètes fine page antibiotiques
pas de ger le lait aujourd'hui est plus
pur qu'il ne l'a jamais été
et dans cette centrale laitière qui trop
diffus de 5000 litres de lait par jour
grâce aux efforts conjugués de près de
25 mille vaches dans cette centrale ont
fait des quantités de lait des lectures
is aider les pêcheurs river délai à
l'ong conservation et pour cela on veut
leur peur on va leur faire subir des
parcs bâtiment
on va aller on va les pitres et on
elle est chauffée on va les refroidir on
va même les projeter violemment pour
femmes eurent en inoxydable ceci pour
les homogénéiser mais en tout cas je
trouve toujours que des traitements
physiques et jamais jamais on ajoutera
que ce soit au lait c'est la loi et
autour de son passage dans l'île
ce lait depuis sa collecte jusqu'à sa
sortie
recevez de multiples analyse et
traitement pour vérifier qu'il est
toujours aussi pure ben bravo martine on
va voir tous ces traitements tout à
leurs autres points je vous les 10
montpellier montpellier jean claude
allanic de bonsoir bonsoir leur ont
effectivement les sommes à montpellier
place de la canourgue où les
montpelliérains peuvent d'ailleurs nous
rejoindre s'ils veulent assister en
direct à cette émission
montpellier c'est à deux pas de la mer
la mer et c'est pour ça que nous allons
parler ici surtout de poissons pollués
peut-être par le mercure
le mercure qui est d'une part en quelque
sorte un témoin de la pollution des mers
et d'autre part en forte quantité qui
est surtout un poison pour l'organisme
humain
alors comment avons nous organiser notre
opération vient avec l'aide de la mairie
avec l'aide de la presse locale mais dès
libre et le jura le montpellier l'avant
demandé aux consommateurs en pèlerin de
nous apporter des échantillons de
poissons des sardines et maquereaux du
thon etc
ces échantillons sont dans des bocaux
ici et je peux vous dire d'ailleurs que
cela a beaucoup motivés et passionnés
l'union départementale des consommateurs
de l'hérault et puis nous allons dans la
soirée analyser ces poissons
nous découvrirons tout à l'heure les
résultats de ses analyses sur ce tableau
ces analyses ont été effectuées dans un
laboratoire le laboratoire de la
répression des fraudes qui est cité à
deux pas de cette place et nous serons
en mesure en fin de cette soirée de vous
indiquer si les poissons consommés ici
montpellier sont pollués un peu beaucoup
ou je l'espère pour les montpelliérains
pas du tout eh bien c'est ce que nous
espérons également genthod dynamique
mais mais nous sommes à montpellier nous
sommes à clermont sur oise nous sommes
également en direct ici à paris et avec
vous avec vous pour vous demander de
participer en intervenant nous
composé par l'intermédiaire de la presse
trois questions et avec ce deuxième but
nous allons tenter ce soir un sondage on
dirait qu'ils ont de prendre un petit
peu le pouls de vos idées allant nous
avons posées aux 360 0202 que vous
pouvez appeler 16 1 360 020 2 si vous
appelez de la province trois questions
première question avez vous vérifié si
votre huile vient d'espagne je répète
votre huile vient d'espagne
deuxième question et vous voyez
actuellement les seize standardiste qui
vont recueillir au 360 0202 vos réponses
deuxième question mangez-vous des
champignons cueillis par vous même ou
par vos proches
mangez-vous des champignons cueillis par
vous même ou par vos proches enfin une
troisième question peut-être un peu plus
larges et bien vous sentez vous vous
même vous même personnellement à l'abri
des risques alimentaires et bien tout au
long de cette émission grâce aux
ordinateurs de ces deux et grâce à
surtout à vous appelle je le rappelle
aux 360 02 02 16 1 360 02 02 nous
verrons comment ce sondage express
évolué je pense que maintenant que nous
avons un petit peu plus de connaissance
avec ses décors nouveaux de planète
bleue tout en volume je pense qu'il vous
pour attaquer la première partie de
cette émission vraiment qui est l'huile
l'huile une sombre affaire
tout démarre le 1er mai où tout d'un
coup un jeune homme va mourir en espagne
pour avoir consommé de lui et bien ce
soir ici ces tuiles
j'en ai j'arrive dans un petit flacon
ici c'est pas facile à trouver
et voyez-vous s'est-il pas qu'elle sent
pas très bon moral je vais vous dire
franchement ne sont pas tellement
mauvaise gestion ont versé un petit peu
je vous rassure je ne vais pas la boire
parce que elle est toxique
cela m si vous voulez bien dans cette
salade les personnes ne consommera à
cette salade je pense que personne ici
son plateau on aura envie bien c'est
qu'il a fait des morts c'est qu'il
frelaté et
il ya quelques quinze mille victimes ces
quinze mille victimes il y en a deux
cent trente nord et qu'est ce qui à leur
santé bien d'abord une sorte de
paralysie qui les prend dans ce sens un
peu de pneumonie puis une sorte
d'accalmie
et puis ça repart et la paralysie qui
touche les muscles et progressivement
les poumons à ce moment là il n'y a
pratiquement plus rien à faire c'est la
mort quinze mille personnes sont
menacées personne ne peut dire
actuellement combien mourant pourtant on
a on a un historique on a une graduation
dans cette catastrophe avec le petit
agenda que j'ai ici vous dit le premier
mort c'était le 1er mai 1981 mais
regardez comme c'est allé vite 10 juin
81 23 morts 24 août 100 morts 9
septembre
124 morts 2 octobre 140 morts 12
novembre 190 morts et aujourd'hui direz
vous et bien aujourd'hui 6 janvier 82 il
y actuellement 230 quatre victimes deux
sont mortes
il y a exactement deux jours lundi alors
d'où vient cette huile comment est-ce
que comment est ce que la puce provoquer
nous avons tenté de reconstituer un peu
son parcours infernal tout par batou
parts de quelque chose de très pur tout
par d'accent de colza puis d'une huile
tout ce qui est plus et qui est longue
des huiles de colza d'olive de colza
française de surcroît seulement elle va
subir des traitements et de traitement
que heureusement la rendront impropre à
la consommation
cette huile que je transporte dans un
bidon de 5 litres on va vouloir la
dénaturer pourquoi bien tout simplement
pour qu'elle ne devienne non
consommables pour en faire autre chose
alors on va déverser le dans un liquide
qui s'appelle ici de l'année l'ine qui
comme vous voyez est un produit toxique
dangereux on va en verser dans cette
huile on va mélanger et pourquoi bien
parce qu'à partir de ce moment là cette
huile qui ne sera plus de consommables
et bien elle va pouvoir passer la
frontière d'espagne le poids procès la
frontière d'espagne sans crainte d'avoir
à payer de grandes taxes autrement dit
c'est une l'on consomme al le pôle
pratiquement pas de taxes alors vous me
direz pourquoi on fait ça bien
théoriquement ces tuiles on devrait s'en
servir c'est
il dénature et la verser ici sur cette
établi pour faire
je travaille sur le métal
seulement ça c'était sa destination une
fois dénaturer dans la réalité les
espagnols peu scrupuleux qui ont acheté
cette huile qu'est ce qu'ils vont en
faire
ils vont la chauffer à 200 degrés ils
vont la chauffe est ici à 200 degrés
avec une tétine bien sûr plus élaboré
que ce simple réseau c'est symbolique
pour la roche naturelle pour éliminer
l'aniline le produit toxique qui lie à
l'intérieur ils le savent
selon manque de chance d'une part ils
vont partir et toute la nuit ensuite
cette décomposition va fixer l'aniline
sur des acides gras et il ya des acides
gras dans l'huile pour créer des années
dans une lettre de différence seulement
un toxique a produit tout aussi en
conclusion et bien c'est huile toxiques
a circulé en bidon de 5 litres
théoriquement rendu à nouveau bonne à la
consommation en fait elle ne l'était pas
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé pas de
là on a pris un camion avec des
bouteilles de 5 litres et on les a
vendues alcorcon de la banlieue de
madrid en remontant ici la nationale 6
s'est passé à valladolid et ses
remontées jusqu'à les hommes on peut
dire que plus de 90% des cas mortels
sont dans ces provinces de l'espagne
quelques autres ailleurs mais c'est
principalement dans ces provinces où ils
étaient vendus par bidon de 5 litres
donc au porte à porte
voilà donc que ces tuiles dangereuse
comment elle s'est retrouvée chez les
consommateurs
vous me direz comment est ce qu'on sait
qu'elle est dangereuse et comment
détectons l'aniline à l'intérieur bien
c'est ce qu'on va voir en direct à
montpellier avec centre-ville nico
servent au laboratoire du service de
répression des fraudes de jean-claude
vers la première question qu'on se pose
ici au laboratoire c'est de savoir si
cette huile qui vient d'espagne est
effectivement en huile d'olive pure ou
un mélange car on sait que l'ul
incriminé est en fait composé d'un
mélange on connaît la nature d'une huile
grâce à la présence relative d'un
certain nombre d'acier de gras vous avez
ici
le graphique qui correspond à de l'huile
de colza
ici vous avez un pic un deuxième pic ce
sont les acides gras mais surtout dans
l'huile de colza il y un pic qui est
très caractéristique
c'est le pic de l'acide linoléique par
contre lorsqu'on a de l'huile d'olive
voici le graphique ici on a des pics
correspondant à différents acides gras
mais surtout on n'a pas le pic
correspondant à l'acide et linolénique
on va donc chercher maintenant dans ce
laboratoire
grâce à cet appareil qui s'appelle un
chromatographie en phase gazeuse savoir
si cette huile est effectivement une
huile de livres première opération on va
injecter disons pour simplifier une
préparation d'huile ces tuiles va passer
dans l'appareil
elle va passer dans cette colonne où va
s'effectuer un partage entre les
différents acides gras qui composent
l'huile ensuite on lira sur un graphique
si vous préférez un chromatographe la
nature exacte de cette huile et sa
composition
voilà le graphique jeu le déchirent et
je vais le comparer maintenant à nos
autres graphie et je vois qu'il y a donc
toujours lépi correspondant ainsi gras
mais surtout il y à ici un pic qui
correspond à la présence d'acide
linoléique c'est à dire que l'huile
d'espagne que nous avons n'est pas une
huile pur c'est une huile mélanger
d'olive et de colza premières
conclusions qui s'imposent
il y a donc eu fraude il y a eu fraude
mais frau de cela ne veut pas dire que
c'est dangereux pour la santé des
consommateurs
donc le problème maintenant va être de
savoir s'il ya ce fameux produits
toxiques
cette année line ou ses dérivés qui sont
les annélides et bien ça on va le savoir
grâce à un autre appareil qui est un
chromatographe également mais en phase
liquide
on va également introduire dans
l'appareil de l'huile ici on va même
temps appuyer sur cette petite pièce et
à l'intérieur de l'appareil
vous avez une colonne dans cette colonne
il y a de la silice dont la propriété
est de séparer les différents
constituants de cette huile et lorsque
ses constituants seront séparés on
pourra donc que remarquée sur le
graphique la présence ou l'absence d
annie leed voilà le graphique
je vais donc
le déchirer et on voit effectivement il
y a trois pics tout à fait
caractéristique de la présence d'annie
lead ces tuiles donc est une huile
effectivement toxiques
cela dit il faut vous précisez peut-être
pour vous rassurer que depuis le début
de la sphère des ultra chic d'espagne en
france je dis bien en france dans les
laboratoires des fraudes
on n'a jamais trouvé de présence d'annie
line dans une ville commercialisé en
france
oui c'était très bon a précisé
jean-claude merci alors l'ennui c'est là
qu'il commence c'est qu'on a un taux de
la vie il ya quelques instants
on a trouvé l'aniline on a trouvé de
l'année lead seulement on n'a pas trouvé
assez en quantité pour tuer se dire
qu'on a dit que c'étaient les annélides
qui tu es dans l'huile frelatée et bien
sans doute pas puisqu'il y en a pas
assez alors qu'est-ce qui a tué les
animaux
et bien finalement même si c'est un
marqueur de l'huile empoisonné on n'en
est pas sûr alors on fait d'autres
hypothèses
première hypothèse c'est que sur les 110
tonnes d'huile frelatée espagnol et
n'aurait que quelques tonnes voire
quelques centaines de litres corps
étaient toxiques et celle là qu'on les
aurait jamais vu les orange a man is et
les aurais tu es belle se seraient
perdus dans des bouteilles dans des
fonds de dévier et dans des salades
deuxième hypothèse et bien en fait il y
a dans l'huile un nom autre poison ce
poison n'a toujours pas trouvé on n'a
pas analysé après six mois de travail et
ce poison et donc inconnue c'est
troisième hypothèse sans doute la plus
vraisemblable une autre et bien c'est
quand même temps que les espagnols ont
consommé de lui l'on consommé outils aux
un produit inconnu qui lui aurait était
toxique et qui finalement ma foi c'est
pas lui le corps était à sausheim et
l'autre produits consommés avec cette
hypothèse est peu vraisemblable a
pratiquement été écartée autre hypothèse
plus délicate et bien s'est aperçu qu'il
y avait parmi les morts deux femmes sur
trois dans une même famille on ne
trouvait qu'un seul mort sur 5 en
moyenne
ça signifie que les gens ne réagissent
pas de la même manière à cette file
frelaté et on pense peut-être à quelque
chose qu'on pourrait qualifier de tares
génétiques qui différencierait les
malades par rapport à cette donc huile
toxiques
et puis voyez j'ai mis un point
d'interrogation parce qu'en fait en fait
on ne sait pas on n'est pas sûr et c'est
ça qui est incroyable dans cette
histoire
ces cas après six mois où les
laboratoires en france à lyon en
particulier et à montpellier on analyser
tout ça on ne sait toujours pas ce que
c'est il ya même des gens qui disent
qu'on laissera son visa mais espérons
tout de même si ça sera toujours trop
tard pour trouver un antidote d'ailleurs
hypothétique alors j'en arrive à mon
sondage ces musiques
j'ai tout de suite prendre la première
la réponse de la première question qui
était je vous le rappelle avez vous
vérifié si votre huile vient d'espagne
depuis 20 heures vous avez appelé somme
après donc un peu plus 38 les appels ont
été contactés de 20h15 à peu près voyez
que nous avons une très grande stabilité
avec 55 points 4 % de gens qui ont
vérifié
alors ça vous dire franchement je suis
très surpris je découvre ces chiffres
avec vous je m'attendais à ce que je
suis pas une personne sur cinq a regardé
s'il n'y avait pas de l'huile dans ses
placards blanc d'espagne
j'ai vraiment plus d'un français sur
deux alors ceci dit c'est peut-être
parce que c'est vous qui avez voulu nous
dire que vous aviez vérifier que vous
étiez inquiet il n'empêche que le
sondage est là une autre question que
j'ai posée
tout à l'heure on verra le sondage
évoluer dans la au cours de la soirée
c'est sur les champignons non j'ai vous
des champignons cueillis par vous même
vos projets bien finalement voulait me
dire que 55 % également à manger les
champignons cueillis dans la forêt ce
qui signifie en fin de compte bien vous
êtes quand même 45 % à être méfiants et
bien je vais vous dire vous avez quand
même un tout petit peu raison d'être
méfiants et puis nous allons voir
maintenant en nous dirigeant vers la
deuxième partie de cette émission ou
ensemble on va tenter de comprendre ce
qui se passe un truc à nice mme comment
est bien une petite molécule comme ça
dans un produit va s'introduire il va
venir déréglé cette belle machine qu'est
l'homme mais je voudrais vous montrez là
quand même
c'est assez beau je voudrais vous
démontrez vous montrer ici d'abord une
amanite tue mouche voilà c'est très
difficile trouvant ses saisons je vous
le signale
voilà l'amanite tue mouches ici
l'amanite phalloïde je la prends avec
des gants parce que il faut faire
attention et bien ces deux champignons
sont les plus mortels surtout l'amanite
phalloïde que j'ai ici vous dites il ya
environ 12 en moyenne 12 cents cas
d'intoxication par champignons en france
en une année et 6 cas mortels c'est
assez c'est assez incroyable et une des
légendes antiques aux actions dites les
champignons
eh bien le noir 6 pas l'argent alors on
est une petite pièce en argent dans la
casserole et puis si ça noir si bas
c'est que c'est bon je crois que c'est
une mauvaise solution et c'était à cause
de bêtises comme ces lieux communs comme
ça qu'il y ait encore des morts avec
tout ça je laisse aux mouchoirs
comment est-ce que ces morts
interviennent vient toujours un peu de
la même manière par bien sûr le tube
digestif l'intestin et l'estomac et
ensuite par le foie ce le x va être là
la place centrale si vous voulez c'est
là que vont se disperser tous les
produits dans le corps humain alors
revoyons produit par produit si vous le
voulez bien
pour commencer à tout seigneur tout
honneur par les champignons moi j'ai une
soupe
ici peu ragoûtantes eh bien ces
champignons voilà ces champignons ils
vont attaquer d'une part les reins
famille bouchon d'une part les reins
d'une part le fois encore une nécrose
roman une attaque des cellules du foin
et durera leur mort est donc
progressivement une intoxication avec
une molécule qui s'appelle la phalloïde
digne du nom de l'amanite phalloïde
continuons avec l'huile l'huile
d'espagne et bien s'est-il d'espagne
elle commet à quelle partie du corps
c'est l attaquer eh bien elle s'est
attaquée pour sa part aux muscles
principalement aux muscles et le grand
problème
et quand c'est le muscle pulmonaire qui
étaient touchés car c'est là qu'il y
avait donc la mort ensuite 3e deux
autres produits que nous étudierons dans
cette émission le lait effectivement il
ya eu des problèmes des craintes pour le
lait il ya deux ans et bien selon lui
voilà le lait il s'attaque pour sa part
également au foie ici il y eut des
cancers du foie au sénégal à cause du
lait contenant une molécule qui
s'appelle l'aflatoxine dont nous
reparlerons tout à l'heure dans les
produits que nous allons voir c'est le
poisson ici d'une soupe de poisson alors
pourquoi du poisson parce qu'on trouve
du poisson dans le poisson une certains
métaux lourds comme le mercure le
cadmium et on s'attaque directement aux
systèmes
un peu autrement dit au cerveau et
d'ailleurs je voudrais qu'on continue
justement avec ce système n'a volé ce
cerveau car ces métaux lourds qui en
fait d'ailleurs c'est pas tout à fait le
mercure qui joue ce sont des et compose
des lits mercure comme dites leur de
merde que ce qu'on appelle des organes
au mercuriels eh bien ils ont fait des
victimes
il ya quand même longtemps né en 1956 à
comment 156 au japon à minamata que je
me souvienne 50 victimes 50 morts et
plusieurs centaines de personnes qui ont
été intoxiquées
les drapeaux noirs qui défilent devant
l' usine de la jso corporation
représentent chacun la vie d'un habitant
de minamata cette usine rejetés dans les
eaux de la baie un composé de mercure en
apparence bien assimilé par les poissons
dont se nourrissaient les pêcheurs du
village
or la chair de ces poissons était
empoisonné les consommateurs atteint de
troubles neurologiques graves leurs
membres paralysés leur système nerveux
toucher certains devenait aveugle
d'autres nouvelles
au début en 1956 on a cru à une épidémie
de poliomyélite
mais très vite on s'est rendu compte que
c'était autre chose et peu à peu les
dirigeants de la chine ont été mises en
accusation lors des assemblées générales
que les familles des victimes
envahissait provoquant des enquêtes et
ceux qu'on l'appareil réglementaire le
jugement de culpabilité n'a été rendu
qu'en mars 1973 c'est la nuit après la
première alerte alors les directeurs de
la compagnie ont dû verser plus de 13
milliards de centimes d'indemnisation
est assurée dans différents centres le
traitement et la rééducation des malades
la pêche est maintenant interdite dans
la baie de minamata et ceci jusqu'à la
fin du siècle
oui le plus extraordinaire dans cette
histoire c'est que c'est il ya seulement
six mois qu'on a c'est un petit peu le
fin mot de l'histoire enfin pense-t-on
en tout cas c'est pas vraiment le
mercure qui serait en cause mais un
virus qui se serait développée à la
faveur de la présence du maire que
c'était pour ça d'ailleurs combat qu'on
n'a pas trouvé la faille 25 ans pour
trouver la cause réelle de la sphère de
minamata et on n'a donc rien pu faire
alors est-ce qu'il ya du mercure dans
les poissons huile tehrani est-ce que ça
augmente mais c'est la question qu'on
peut se poser c'est pourquoi nous avons
monté avec le service de répression des
fraudes
une expérience en direct avec vous à
montpellier à montpellier nous allons
nous rendre tout de suite oui
effectivement je suis avec madame
maaseik est une des consommatrices qui
nous apportait du poisson en
l'occurrence il s'agit du maquereau
j'espère que vous le voyez puisqu'on
avait un tout petit problème de lumière
mais qui va bientôt être réglés et dans
ce laboratoire
nous allons chercher à savoir s'il ya du
mercure dans ce poisson est bien sûr
quelle quantité de mercure
l'opération va se faire en deux temps
premier temps ici on va chercher à
minéralisée le poisson
j'ai pris quelques grammes de poisson et
puis sur cet appareil on va donc
minéralisée le poisson dans ce ballon il
ya de l'acide nitrique il y à de l'acide
sulfurique qui en quelque sorte est en
train d'éliminer complètement les
matières organiques du poisson il ne
restera dans le ballon que les matières
minérales les métaux et notamment le
mercure
ensuite il faudra passer à la deuxième
phase de cette opération et nous allons
donc avec notre solution de poissons
minéralisée nous rendre dans une autre
partie du laboratoire où là nous allons
chercher à mesurer à doser la teneur en
mercure et ceci grâce à un appareil très
compliqué qui s'appelle un
spectrophotomètre absorption atomique
alors on va donc que dans un premier
temps introduire une partie de notre
solution de poissons minéralisée dans ce
vase
on va mettre ce vase sur l'appareil et
puis on va produire une réaction
chimique je simplifie qui va en quelque
sorte projeter les atomes de mercure
contenu dans ce poisson dans cette
cellule cette cellule qui est
véritablement le coeur de cet appareil
car également dans cette
dans cette cellule va être projeté un
rayonnement un faisceau de photons dont
la longueur d'onde va correspondre à
celle du mercure
les médias japonais
oui c'est un laser si vous voulez donc
les le mercure contenu dans le poisson
va absorber une partie de ce rayonnement
pour simplifier si vous voulez si vous
avez un rayonnement 1 ap torsion très
grande il y aura une grande quantité de
mercure si au contraire l'absorption est
faible on aura une faible quantité et
les résultats vont se lire lorsque vous
aurez donc enclenché cette opération les
résultats vont se lire ici sur ce cadran
ou vont être enregistrées ici sur ce
graphique mais la lecture n'est pas
direct il faudra pour lire la quantité
de mercure contenu dans ce poisson
utilisé un étalon alors madame mazel on
va se rapprocher et on voit donc que il
y a dans votre poisson 0,4 ppm de
mercure les ppm de mercure apprécié ça
veut dire en fait 0,4 mg de mercure par
kg de poissons étudiés
en fait c'est un seuil qui est
relativement important puisque le seuil
légal autorisé est de 0,5 mais nous
pourrons commenter ces résultats et les
résultats des autres analyses que nous
allons effectuer ici tout à l'heure
voilà j'espère que madame et quand tant
de savoir quand il ya 2 ppm et 2 mg de
mercure par kilo de de ces macro alors
comment est-ce que ce mercure s'est
retrouvé là eh bien c'est ce qu'on va
voir maintenant c'est un spa que le
poisson a été pêché en méditerranée
parce qu'on va parler de la méditerranée
donc le mercure ou plutôt les composés
il tenait dans la main ici
un kilo de merde c'est pas grave c'est
folie que c'est lourd en fait c'est
dense avec encore le même symbole de
tête de mort ici bien ce mercure ou
plutôt les composés organo mercuriale
qui contiennent ce mercure va déverser
aussi bien par l'industrie que par les
hommes que par les consommateurs dans
leur home progressivement tout au long
de son cours et ça va donner donc que
ici cette chute du mercure dans la
méditerranée où donc il va venir polluer
d'être cueillis par tous les organismes
vivants qui à l'intérieur
par exemple le plancton ce que le
phytoplancton aux plantes autrement dit
le plancton végétal le plancton animal
ça c'est la base de tout c'est le départ
car après eh bien ce plancton va être
consommée par d'autres poissons et c'est
le début du cycle infernal qui commence
début de ce qu'on appelle la chaîne
alimentaire et l'accumulation de ce
mercure dans la chaîne alimentaire
en effet ce plancton et mangé par le
petit poisson qui est ici et puis vous
savez ce que c'est il ya toujours un
gros poisson pour manger le petit et
puis un moyen poisson
pour manger le petit patient évidemment
le poisson lui est digérée et retourne à
la mer sous forme d excréments mais les
billes elle reste le mercure reste à
l'intérieur puis au bout de sienne
qu'est ce qu'on trouve le gros prédateur
on trouve le ton lui contient beaucoup
d'autant plus que ce ton lui vit très
longtemps alors non seulement il va
recevoir le poisson les touts les le
mercure de tout le cadmium de toul et
les poissons qu'il a ingurgité pendant
sa vie mais en plus il a baigné dans ce
milieu par ses branchies par ses
écailles il va s'imprégner de mercure
c'est pourquoi le ton lui en acceptant
que 0 5 et 0 7 ppm de tolérance pour le
ton c'est lui qui contient le plus de
mercure et de métaux lourds en
méditerranée mais où on est la
méditerranée nous avons voulu le savoir
et laurent boucher s'est rendu à
marseille dans le port de marseille en
bateau et même dans l'île des embiez à
la rencontre d'un spécialiste en la
matière qui s'appelle alain bombard la
pollution en méditerranée par les métaux
lourds
c'est vous et c'est moi car en réalité à
52%
la pollution provient des grandes
agglomérations humaine est seulement à
48 % proviennent de des grandes
industries par conséquent c'est nous les
consommateurs qui sommes les pollueurs
alors le grand problème c'est de savoir
comment va se terminer cette
accumulation dans la chaîne alimentaire
en tout cas il ya une chose certaine
qu'on ne peut pas continuer
ouah ouah
si nous continuons comme cela est bien
le poisson deviendra contingenté faut 50
à genté parce que la quantité de métaux
lourds dans notre organisme deviendra
dangereuses ces métaux lourds qui sont
le cadmium le mercure le plomb qui sont
des toxiques violent vous mangerez que
deux poissons par mois et pas plus et
déjà fait au japon et en norvège
or le poisson c'est la vie il faut pas
oublier qu'on ne peut pas indéfiniment
augmenter les quantités de protéines
produites par la tête alors que
maintenant on luttera de travail et se
met à cette merveilleuse solution que
peut-être l'aquaculture c'est à dire
l'apport d'une nourriture protéinique
pour les pays qui meurent de faim et par
conséquent nous devons alors qu'elle
travaille à l'heure actuelle doit se
centrer sur la diminution de la quantité
de métaux lourds qui entre dans le lot
dans le milieu on va se développer cette
chaîne alimentaire
pour cela et bien il faut faire un
effort
au fond on a diagnostiqué la maladie
maintenant il faut la guérir alors il ya
deux moyens et de moyens nécessaires
premièrement arrêté
l'injection de poison donc faire des
stations d'épuration qui soient des
stations d'épuration efficace et ensuite
nettoyé c'est à dire restituer les lieux
vous ne faites pas de culture d'épinards
sur un terry de charbon vous ne ferez
pas d'aquaculture un endroit où vous
avez des accumulations de métaux lourds
qui pénètre dans la chaîne alimentaire
comme nous l'avons vu précédemment
la consommation de près ce qu'on parle
augmenté elle pointe augmenté pour
assurer le l'equilibre protéinique dans
le monde et pour cela la première
démarche celle avoir un milieu propre
donc des poissons qu'ils soient des
poissons de bonne qualité oui la grande
leçon de ce que vient de dire alain
bombard c'est également que nous sommes
tous responsables ne serait ce qu'au
titre de la participation que nous avons
dans notre société
alors j'entends de la nique à
montpellier quels sont les résultats de
cette fameuse analyse et je crois que
parmi tous les échantillons à porter on
ne la choisit 10 est-ce que c'est
positif est ce que c'est négatif mais à
voulez savoir tout de suite ici quelques
secondes le temps que nous nous rendions
au tableau nous avons affiché ses
résultats bien sûr il n'ya pas les
résultats de toutes les analyses
uniquement 10 résultats qui ont été
tirés au sort à mazet d'ailleurs ma
compagne avec son vocal de maquereaux
alors première chose qu'il faut savoir
c'est donc que ces résultats sont
exprimés en ppm
on les dit tout à l'heure sont des
parties par million en l'occurrence des
dixièmes de mg pour 1 kg de poissons
analysés et il y à un trek est très
important ici c'est ce trait rouge
ce trait rouge qui définit la norme
légale 0,5 ppm tous les poissons qui
sont situées au delà au dessus de 0 5
ppm en dehors du cas particulier des
tons sont des poissons qui ne sont pas
consommables qui contiennent trop de
mercure par contre tous les poissons
situé à gauche sont tout à fait
concevable et vous voyez que nous avons
eu de la chance il n'y a pas beaucoup de
problèmes de pollution actuellement à
montpellier car presque tous nos
poissons sont situés dans une zone de
zéro 0,1 au maximum 0,2 ppm par contre
celui ci c'est un combres d'ailleurs qui
nous a été communiqué par madame velits
contient 0,6 ppn il n'est pas concevable
il est trop pollué et puis madame mazet
nous allons mettre votre mac row qui lui
donc à 0,4 ppm qui se situe ici voyez
qu'il n'est pas très loin de la limite
il est juste à la limite mais enfin
théoriquement il n'a pas être saisi par
la répression des fraudes car il est
tout à fait concevable
donc la situation à montpellier n'est
pas désespérée oui et vous avais prévenu
jean-claude la dame qui a un congre
incongrue à 0 6 ppm
eh bien nous allons lui la prévenir et
surtout lui déconseillé de manger ce
congrès bon merci jean tôt pour cette
expérience et je pense que dans chaque
émission tu peux nous tenterons de
trouver ainsi une manière d'y faire
participer à cette émission planète
bleue avec une expérience avec vous
alors donc avec cette deuxième partie de
l'émission
nous avons vu si l'on peut dire le grand
mécanisme l'un des grands mécanismes de
d'intoxication alimentaire qui le
phénomène de l'accumulation potence un
peu à elle négligé en avance à penser
que cette accumulation bien elle n'est
pas très importante seulement elle elle
est importante à long terme et donc
comme le dit alain bombard il faudra y
faire attention
et puis il ya de temps en temps autre
chose il y aller les accidents et ses
accidents à les évoquer pour terminer
cette émission avec d'abord ici
pont-saint-esprit dans cet esprit en
1951 dans la nuit du 15 au 16 août et
bien un boulanger à fabriquer du pain eh
bien je me suis rendu à
pont-saint-esprit en compagnie de jean
pierre spiero je me suis rendu à
pont-saint-esprit pour pour retrouver
dans les jambes et dans les pierres les
traces de cet événement pour voir quelle
est l influence sur la population
croyez moi dans tous ces hommes et dans
toutes ses pieds à bien les souvenirs
sont présents cela commença comme une
intoxication alimentaire banal ensuite
il y eut la période d'euphorie et puis
la période d'hystérie des malades
voulurent se jeter par exemple dans le
rhône dont l'airé vite à ce malheur de
justesse un autre et bien il se mit à
giflé une femme une femme morte dix ans
auparavant
certains virent autour d'eux des bêtes
féroces des monstres voire le plus
souvent un incendie cela dura des jours
des semaines pour certains d'entre eux
qui tentèrent ainsi d'échapper au
cauchemar qu'ils vivaient à ben ça moi
je sais ce qu'on m'a dit soit disant
qu'on devenait fou bien sûr vous êtes
devenue folle et bien sûr j'étais à
montfavet c'est à dire mais on était à
montfavet où on était plus à soir
reconnaissait personne et vous n'arrivez
pas dormi aussi l heure après ce séjour
terre on n'avait toujours pas tout a
commencé ici à la boulangerie briand rue
joliot-curie un ou deux sacs de farine
contaminés par quoi bien soin par un
fongicide un produit chimique contenant
les organes au mercuriels soit plus
logiquement par l'ergot ce parasite des
céréales que l'on trouve dans le sel
toujours est il que de la boulangerie
brillant aujourd'hui il ne reste
pratiquement que les murs mais les
autres boulangers de l'époque à pau cet
esprit se souviennent mieux colombet
vous vous étiez là allez pas vous étiez
boulanger mais ce jour là je crois que
vous aviez fermer votre boulangerie
c'est à dire que ce jour là je rentre de
congé alors comment ça s'est passé
qu'est ce que vous aviez
j'ai entendu parler vaguement nosta
faire mais c'est pas encore bien une
verte alors nous aurons travaillé cette
nuit là c'est le coup de 7 heures du
matin à peu près on va arriver à dire
deux municipales j'ouvre illégal
gendarmes ensemble en usant de suite à
un tir de peine et lui dire que mario
est maudit vous le serez plus tard et
fermer immédiatement la boulangerie
c'est ce que nous avons fait et
plusieurs de vos clients sont morts
parce qu'ils ont été prendre le pas les
autres y eut cette personne morte
j'imagine qu'à l'époque vous ne vendrez
pratiquement plus de pain et comme
ronald chammah cheveux tout de même les
jarrets tellement peur qu'ils prévoient
des biscottes remplacer le pen les
biscottes il faut dire que dans les rues
pour cet esprit se passer beaucoup de
choses
drame dans la rue drame à l'hôpital où
des dizaines de malades sont comme fou
avec des hallucinations et des
cauchemars
l'un d'eux se jettera même de la fenêtre
du deuxième étage comme s'ils se prenait
pour un avion en fait il se sentait
comme entouré par un incendie
il faut dire que la des produits émis
par les ragots de sel est très proche du
lsd
est ce que vous pouvez me raconter la
sphère le cas de madame payant du
compagnon était un parmi les autres elle
brûlait ll avait du feu au bout des
doigts et alors elle me faisait de
tarbes tard ne vous approchez pas ne
l'approchez pas de moi car vous avez
quatre enfants et je ne veux pas que que
vous vouliez au feu qui sort de mes
doigts ça c'est guéri
ben fois guéri ou pas guéri la wii la
maladie des nerfs c'est un dur jusqu'à
la fin jusqu'à sa mort sa 10e sa part
avait la personne la maladie des nerfs
ça se guérit jamais monsieur
médicalement parlant nous avons dû de
l'idée de l'ergot de seigle d'emblée et
puis un an après nous avons eu la
théorie de la halle qui me merkel qui
est venue se greffer là dedans mais
pourquoi c'était pour protéger qui les
protégeaient portes et nous protéger des
intérêts des intérêts des intérêts une
madjer de l'état kkr l'onic était un
organisme d'état qui disent il faut les
abus et les héparines les farines
l'allèle l'état ne devait pas avoir tort
et puis c'est fini je crois que c'est
comme ça qu'il faut voir le problème
ainsi l'hypothèse du poison paragano
mercuriels ne convainc personne ici à
pont-saint-esprit où l'on croit toujours
à l'ergot de seigle
alors bien sûr on avait mis à l'époque
en prison le boulanger et le minotier on
les a relâchés avec un non-lieu car
trente ans après on ne sait toujours pas
avec certitude ce qui a tué à
pont-saint-esprit l' enquête officielle
est close
l'enquète véritable n'est pas terminée
elle ne le sera jamais et c'est un
deuxième exemple nous voyons avec lui
l'espagnol ben c'est pas si simple
minamata aussi faut des années pour
trouver et puis malheureusement faut
quelques minutes pour créer un drame et
on l'a cru avec le long du port avec
l'ajout rassure tout de suite tout va
bien avec avec le legs vous concerne
actuellement mis n'empêche il n'empêche
qu'il ya deux ans il eu des inquiétudes
à 6 g/j mignonne qui est charmante tue
tout à fait mignonne tout à fait mais
vous j'ai dû pour cette émission c'est
que j'ai une performance par émission
comme d'objectifs demain voilà tu viens
mignonne
voilà voilà voilà vous m'excuser je
parle pas trop fort j'ai cessé de me
baisser c'est de faire quelque chose que
j'ai jamais fait de ma vie auparavant
j'ai fait ici en direct pour la première
fois voilà comment ce que j'aime être
enfin ici voilà et jetterait en bas âge
est bien là là là je l'est devenue union
est parfaitement bon je peux vous
l'assurer presque envie d'en boire
m'enfin c'est pas peut-être pas évident
voilà elle est mignonne et parfaitement
et parfaitement bon mais mais mais mais
mais mais il faut dire qu'on a beaucoup
de contrôle sur ce lait et puis parce
que parce que d'abord on est dans une
société maintenant où l'industrie fait
des efforts on va le voir tout de suite
et puis parce que je vous ai dit
quelques pépins et quelques craintes
mais parlons pas tout de suite des
pépins voyons déjà comment travailles
l'industrie en direct de clermont sur
oise martin dupuis vraiment navrant
d'avoir vos retraites où haïti
on ne donne en mille litres de lait
continuent à circuler dans l'ue
pour des raisons évidentes d'affectif on
ne le voit jamais nous et nous sommes en
face d'une machine qui faire à
conditionner stérilement du lait stérile
et pour cela il faut en fin d'opération
faire une thermos soudure qui est une
opération assez délicate et le pilote de
la machine va vérifier que cette machine
est bien réglé avec une hotte retraite
qu'il va poser sur la la soudure d'une
brique une brique toutes les 10 minutes
qu'ils prélèvent comme toi dans la
production
voilà le lait donc terrible quand il
arrive dans cette boîte comment elle
attend stérilité eh bien on l'a fait
passer dans une
machine à stériliser en continu et on a
élevé sa température jusqu'à 140 degrés
d'où son nom eut acheté ultra haute
température
il en sort sans aucun gel revelli fiable
n'est en revanche une sûreté on va
encore le médecin jeu
depuis écu dans des conditions optimales
pour que germe tous mes proches depuis
tu peux développer s'il y en avait à
l'intérieur et il y avait un peu
rob qui est résulté aux traitements
précédents eh bien on en trouverait
bemis
l'ips à la sortie de l'étude
prof qui est évidemment aurait dénaturé
le lait aurait changé sa composition
mais cette composition que cette
laborantine contrôle
et bien sûr si je vais pas prendre une
brique au hasard comme beaucoup et vous
et messi je faisais le contrôle avec une
mauvaise brique on verrait que le
liquide réagit différemment mais cette
griffe cette mauvaise briques porte les
chiffres de la palette de la machine de
la roger est au courant situé à un quart
d'heure très le moment où elles étaient
fabriquées donc
monter très vite au lait incriminé vous
voyez donc laurent elle est absolument
sans vert néon rouge
veut pas dire que d'autres substances
toxiques n'aurait pas pu déguster comme
des aplats tôt qu'ils en parleront tout
à l'heure oui bah oui martin
moi je suis moi je suis toujours avec ma
vache avec mignonne décidément décidé
moi je m'habitue et j'ai peine à penser
que mignonne a produit seulement deux
ans du lait dans lequel il y avait une
petite dose d'un petit quelque chose qui
n'était pas très sain qui est un peu de
toxiques pour rappel c'est terminé on
fait tout de même on va continuer cette
histoire car était de jean-pierre bouge
pas millionnaire je reviens c'est
l'histoire de l'aflatoxine alors qu'est
ce qui s'est passé bien tout part oui
tout part de très loin
tout part du sénégal au sénégal en effet
ces hommes ramasse là sur cette
photographie de l'arachide
figurez-vous que l'arachide on en fait
on en fait des tourteaux voici des
tourteaux d'arachide que j'ai ici sous
différentes formes
et si toto d'arachide forme une
nourriture formidable pour les vaches
concentré or il se trouve que sur ces
tourteaux d'arachide se développent une
moisissure et cette moisissure et bien
elle va sécréter une molécule une toxine
qui s'appelle l'aflatoxine c'est une
émission scientifique en plus d'une
émission de vie quotidienne alors je
vais vous montrer la tête de la molécule
d'aflatoxine la voilà on rentrera pas
dans les détails
peu importe solide c'est quand même
compliqué ceci dit bah c'est pas non
plus et elles pouvant table c'est
simplement un assemblage d'un certain
nombre d'atomes bien cette offre à
toxines et toxiques
alors comment ça s'est retrouvé dans la
vache bien c'est très simple avant les
vaches c'est la laisse surtout manger
dans l'herbe elle prenait temps en temps
un peu de tourteaux sur lequel se
développe est ma foi ces produits et ces
moisissures et donc la fête aux-in mais
mais mais mais mais mais mais mais
globalement ça se passait bien on
trouvait de l'aflatoxine dans l'est de
laval
mais jusqu'à 20 ppt va parti pour three
lions en partie pour three lions c'est
le millionième du ppm dont vous parlez
allanic tout à l'heure c'est à dire
c'est pratiquement un grain de sel dans
une piscine olympique
imaginez vous un grain de sel dans une
piscine olympique s'est pratiquement et
empêche qu'on en trouvait mais très peu
et puis et puis comme on a concentré la
nourriture de la vache avec des
tourteaux d'arachide et bien
progressivement le taux a monté avec la
concentration de l'arachide en atteint
300 ppp c'est à dire quinze fois plus
qu'avant et là c'est devenu dangereux
s'est aperçu qu'on sénégal des jeunes
enfants move est de cancer du foie alors
alors on a eu peur on a réduit
l'importation des tourteaux d'arachide
on a contrôlé dans toutes les usines de
conditionnement de lait en france et
dans le monde
on est revenu maintenant au niveau
originale de vin et péter à peu près il
y avait des gens qui disent que la fa
toxines c'est toujours toxiques ça
donnera toujours peut-être quelques
maladies mais que voulez-vous ne peut
pas éviter tous les revenus au statu quo
d'avant à la nature telle qu'elle était
peut-être il ya mille ans
c'était déjà un très grand point et
dijon on l'a échappé un petit peu mais
voilà martine on va retourner chez vous
car vous étudiez je crois à la fête est
finie ce que votre lait à vous il est de
la fête au kiel ou plutôt elle vous sûr
qu'il n'y en a pas et bien laurent on
peut dire qu'il n'y en a quasiment pas
puisque le taux que l'on trouve à
voisine avec le minimum que peut
détecter la machine
néanmoins un plan de surveillance est
assurée par le service vétérinaire du
ministère de l'agriculture auquel les
industriels du lait vous confier leurs
échantillons on voit comme pour lui le
tout alors utilisé une méthode dite de
chromatographie on dépose de l'extrait
de l'est sur une place une plaque qui
est enduite de silice cette plaque on va
la tremper dans une cuve contenant un
solvant le solvant va monter par
capillarité entraînant et ses paroles et
différents constituants la plaque
ensuite imbibé n'est pas visible à la
lumière naturelle
on va l'exposer à des rayons
ultraviolets et voici ce que l'on
obtient ici nous avons les tâches qui
sont de la toxine pu et donc en face on
voit tout de suite les échantillons sur
lesquels portent certains doutes
ensuite on va poser cette flaque sur un
enregistreur qui va nous donner
immédiate
la traduction de la valeur des tâches en
chiffres et en graff
voilà et nous allons pouvoir calculer
notre taux d'aflatoxine mais on veut
encore savoir si dans notre lait on
aurait pas d antibiotiques vous savez
que le lait avec des antibiotiques est
formellement interdits à la
commercialisation il n'empêche que
certains cultivateurs oublie de prévenir
quand ils ont soigné une vache malade
pour cela aux grains procéder à une
petite expérience dans une boîte de
pétri contenant un milieu un milieu de
culture adéquat
on va mettre un germe qui seraient
sensibles à l'antibiotique on va mettre
un germe qui va être sensible à
l'antibiotique et on va rajouter
quelques petites pastilles de papier
buvard que l'on aura imprégné du lait
que l'on veut analyser ensuite de quoi
on va mettre tout ça à l'étude à incuber
et voilà le résultat
alors je vais essayer de bien vous le
montrer que ce soit bien visible je sais
pas si vous voyez mélange parfait martin
alors ici autour des pastilles conteuse
imprégné d'un lait contenant des
antibiotiques le gerb n'a pas pu se
développer jusqu'à la bastille par
contre à d'autres endroits on voit très
bien que le germe se développer jusqu'au
bord de la bastille enfin un dernier
contrôle
eh bien c'est ce que c'est plutôt un
contrôle de routine pour les industriels
du lait c'est une année
bactériologique on va mettre toujours
dans une boîte de pétri quelques gouttes
de lait pour voir si les éventuels germe
se développerait et cette boîte on va
encore la mettre en études à incuber et
on va regarder ce qui se passe quand
elle revient de laitue et bien vous
voyez toutes les tâches que vous voyez
attendez je vais essayer de bien la
disposer voilà toutes les tâches que
vous voyez à l'origine c'était un
microbe est évidemment dans ces
conditions idéales il s'est développé et
a fini par former des colonies
comportant des millions et des millions
de micro compoix d'être visible à l'oeil
nu l appareil permet de dénombrer le
nombre de microbes aux militants vous
voyez laurent tous les contrôler toutes
les contraintes auxquelles est soumis le
lait les c'est bien normal puisque c'est
un produit qui est symbole de pureté et
vous voyez que grâce à la science il est
de plus en plus fidèle à son image
oui absolument martin je rappelle le
numéro de téléphone vous pouvez nous
appeler le 360 020 2 360 020 d'eau 0,2
si vous étiez de la province 16 1 360 02
02 après clermont oise que jean merci
nous allons partir à montpellier pouvoir
d'autres analyses car je crois
jean-claude que la palette de ce conte
études ce qui étudie le service de
répression des fraudes est très vaste
oui il est très vaste on ne se contente
pas de rechercher la présence de mercure
dans les poissons honte est à peu près
tous les aliments car vous savez que
tous les aliments un jour ou l'autre
pose problème après quand tous les
aliments son souffle ce matin on se
demande s'ils sont vraiment très sain
si on peut les consommer sans problème
alors contrôler la la qualité des
aliments c'est le travail des
laboratoires des fraudes laboratoires
qui sont d'ailleurs en fait vous le
savez les laboratoires du ministère de
la consommation
et voici quelques échantillons de ce qui
pose problème est de se contrôler un
jour l'autre précis par exemple des
salades des agrumes des fruits et des
légumes
là on va rechercher la trace les traces
de pesticides qui ont pu rester après
des traitements agricoles
on a aussi ici
et bonbons des nougats et c'est là on va
rechercher plutôt les colorants vous
avez qu à des colorants qui sont tout à
fait autorisé car elles ne présentent
pas de danger par contre il ya un
certain nombre de colorants qui sont
interdits car ils sont nocifs pour la
santé humaine et malheureusement
quelquefois bien qu'il soit interdit
on les retrouve dans un certain nombre
de produits je ne parle pas des produits
laitiers martin l'a fait tout à l'heure
il y a des conserves également on ne
cherche pas simplement le mercure dans
les poissons ou dans les concerts on
cherche aussi des traces de teint de
faire de plomb etc
et puis même dans le vin on recherche
quelque chose et là en l'occurrence dans
le vin on cherche la présence de
conservateurs tout ceci donne beaucoup
de travail aux scientifiques qui
d'autant plus qu'ils ont des analyses
qui sont de plus en plus affinée de plus
en plus compliqué mais on peut dire
quand même qu'en france la situation
n'est pas catastrophique et notre
analyse sur le mercure dans les poissons
tout à fait significatives sur dix
échantillons je vous le rappelle 8 ne
poser aucun problème
imposer un problème ce qui prouve qu'il
ya des problèmes de pollution quand même
et puis un deuxième été à la limite
alors je crois donc on peut dire au
consommateur de montpellier qu'ils
peuvent consommer à peu près sans
problème les poissons tout au moins les
8 échantillons qui ne posait pas de
problème qui ne contenait pas de mercure
donc je vais aller les rendre à la
population qui à monsieur n'en sais pas
monsieur rouge et ça c'est le nom du
poisson et à monsieur
monsieur bonnet s'il est là et puis il
ya également monsieur blanchette
si vous voulez donc récupérer monsieur
blanchet vous peut-être on pouvait
récupérer votre échantillons de poissons
vous pouvez le manger sans problème il
ya pas de mercure ceci dit c'est pas
très appétissant après deux journées au
laboratoire merci donc à risque quasi
nul mais mais mais mais est ce que le
risque alimentaire est vraiment nul est
ce qu'on peut dire qu'un jour à force
d'avoir toutes ces analyses on aura un
risque zéro
mais moi personnellement j'en doute y
aura toujours une part de risque
d'ailleurs on accepte dans la mesure où
par exemple on part en voiture si on
acceptait pas le risque zéro si on
acceptait pas le risque qu'un juste un
tout petit peu mais on ne prendrait
jamais sa voiture ne prendra pas l'avion
non plus mais au fait qu'est-ce que le
risque qu'en soit balle au risque c'est
peut-être simplement de d'admettre que
de temps en temps et bien on va
supporter un accident on va avoir à
subir un accident données dugas a résumé
maintenant sa conception du riz sa
définition du risque dans un dessin
animé
[Musique]
le risque c'est toi vu par nous les
humains c'est le nombre restreint de
chance qui nous échoit d'éviter une
catastrophe
mais une catastrophe c'est quoi
vu par la nature cette fois la
catastrophe n'existe pas un soleil
ordinaire explose à chaque seconde des
millions de bombes thermonucléaires
grâce à ces catastrophes la vie est
apparue
mettons de l'hydrogène avec de l'oxygène
on obtiendra de l'eau si par une
catastrophe on ajoute du carbone il en
naîtra du sucre à catastrophe pour l'eau
n'est bonheur pour le sucre de même que
pour l'umih ainsi près du berceau d'un
humain nouveau né on peut se demander
quels risques
il aura d'avoir un petit nid de se faire
mordre un jour un chien enragé ou mieux
c'est pas trop tôt de gagner au loto en
supprimant les risques on supprime la
chance alors que fait la science elles
mesurent les risques sans espoir jamais
de les annihiler
car le risque zéro ne peut pas exister
il y a à peine 20 ans déjà au
millionième once avait mesuré les
substances toxiques
en deçà on pensait le danger écarté
aujourd'hui on sait autres îles
ioniennes tester
comme si on détectait un grain de sel
jeter dans une piscine olad voilà
pourquoi au lieu du risque tout court on
parle maintenant d'un risque acceptable
et dans tous les domaines on accepte
sans cesse notre corps par exemple
contient des bactéries grouillante par
milieu capable aussi bien de nous tuer
que de nous sauver en matière de vie qui
ne risque rien n'a rien
et non qu'ils ne risquent rien à rien
alors pour terminer après notre c'est
notre panorama des bus rosa panorama de
la fin pour voir vraiment dans tous les
drames dont je vous ai parlé en tout
début d'émission quelles sont les
véritables causes
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire passer en
méditerranée avec le poisson avec le ton
bas c'est un problème tout simplement de
pollution il suffit d'éviter la
pollution prennent de société parsys
avant fin quand même on doit pouvoir
trouver des solutions partons par là bas
du côté de la forêt dans la forêt quelle
est la bêtise on l'a vu tout à l'heure
c'est tout simplement l'inconscience
l'inconscience du public j'espère
qu'après cette émission ça a pris un peu
plus de conscience fait qu'il faut
simplement faire attention
ne serait-ce qu'à les voir le pharmacien
avant de manger n'importe quel
champignons et pippa quoi au vieux
remèdes de grand mère
en espagne c'est très simple ce qui a
tué avec l'huile
tout simplement c'est la fraude et la
fraude on peut l'éviter
avec une bonne loi je peux vous dire que
les espagnols actuellement me l'ont dit
ils ont une loi qui va devenir beaucoup
plus sévère avec moins de la tis qui
permet bien sûr d'éviter en moyenne une
mauvaise qualité des produits d'éviter
totalement des accidents graves qui
surviennent seulement parce qu'on finit
par s'habituer à ce que ça soit moyens
comme produit autre solution ici est
bien avec le sénégal avec le lait là
c'est un peu différent c'était ce qu'on
pourrait appeler une méconnaissance
scientifique du sujet au découvre trop
tard quelque chose on a du mal à
l'analyser et c'est malheureusement les
limites de la science la science ne
donne pas la réponse à tout certains
vous diront
heureusement elle a évidemment c'était
pas très positif il n'empêche que c'est
comme ça et puis malgré tout malgré tout
que voulez vous il ya comme à
pont-saint-esprit malgré la science ce
malgré les hommes malgré les lois il ya
de temps en temps tout simplement les
accidents c'était le cas pour cet esprit
nul ne peut dire quand est ce qu'il y
aura un nouvel accident laisse pas une
cité de la fraude mais c'était quand
même un petit peu aussi un accident et
vous qu'est ce que vous en pensez bien
j'ai retourné vers mon sondage je vais
retourner à votre écoute sur mai
les terminaux d'ordinateurs pour voir ce
que vous avez pensé pendant toute ces
messieurs peut-être comment a évolué et
peut-être qui sait votre point de vue
sur la question de reprendre les
questions tenez réponse à la première
question est ce que vous l'avez bien
fier si votre fils vient d'espagne bon
ça va changer c'est logique on est
toujours à 52 6 % vous êtes un peu plus
donc de la moitié de ceux qui nous ont
appelés et vous êtes 12 160 appels qui
ont été enregistrés ce dimanche beaucoup
plient je m'excuse pour ceux qui n'ont
pas pu nous avoir il y avait que cette
analyse on peut pas en mettre quatre
mille c'est bien évident 12 sans appel
enregistré plus de la moitié considère
donc qu'ils ont vérifié si leur huile
venait d'espagne pensent que quand même
c'est imprégné les français vient de ça
se passe outre pyrénées et bien qu'il y
ait zéro bouteilles d'huile qui soit
introduite en france la question sur les
champignons et à peu près pareil vous
êtes à peu près moitié un peu plus de la
moitié a mangé des champignons
ce qui fait que ça signifie que vous
acceptez quelque peu les risques peut
être également que parmi tous ceux qui
nous ont téléphoné beaucoup tout
simplement connaissent les champignons
ce que j'espère pour troisième question
nous découvrons alors ça c'est la
question donc vous sentez vous à l'abri
personnellement des risques alimentaires
alors là c'est une surprise pour moi
c'est une grande surprise pour moi car
ça se passe en bas là il faudrait qu'on
baisse un peu la caméra ses 21 points 3
% 21 3% vous n'êtes qu'un français sur
cinq nous a téléphoné à vous sentir à
l'abri des risques doit vous êtes quand
même 80 % à avoir peur devrait faire un
gros plan sur cette évolution
ça n'a pas bougé pendant toute la durée
de l'émission nous a pas fait changer
d'avis ah si c'est un petit peu baissé
voyez entrevoyez comme c'est intéressant
c'est parti d'un petit en dessous de 26
% qui aviez été peintes qui donc
aviez vous senti à l'abri et vous sentez
moins à l'abri maintenant à 22% donc une
légère chute à léger tassement de
quelques pourcents peut-être que dans
tout cela et bien il y à ma foi tout
simplement le fait que notre émission
vous informe osé notre but ce n'était
pas de répondre à toutes les questions
loin de là c'était plutôt de vous
interroger de vous faire vous interrogez
plein de buts termine
merci à montpellier d'avoir participé
cette émission merci à pierre manceau
wague merci à la merci du puits au mois
prochain nous retrouverons
3 février pour une nouvelle émission
cette fois ci nous parlerons des bébés
de la planète bleue quel est leur avenir
quelles sont ses futurs bébés vous
demande encore une petite patience
regardez bien tous les noms de ceux qui
participent à cette émission qui sont au
générique derrière chacun sinon ce
casque une personne qui a mis tout son
coeur pour préparer ce premier numéro
deux polonais deux bleus ont leur nom à
tous bonsoir merci et on se retrouve le
3 février à 20h30
[Musique]